what would you guys do oh there he is
thought he had gone home already why
don't you go home and come back for the
party
well
we still have to do the exit interview
yes we do
I'll let you in on a little secret I've
been very much looking forward to this
moment very very much I I have been
steeped in anticipation
Toby has been cruising for bruising for
12 years and I am now his Cruise
director and my name is Captain bruzen
wow thanks Michael can I just say that
of all the idiots in all the idiot
villages in all the idiot worlds you
stand alone my friend hello hey
who Do You Think You Are
Toby
yeah
correct
um
what gives what
what gives you the right
um I brought the binder do you want to
take a little look sure you know what
that sounds good I'll take a little
look-see
here we go thank you
what would you improve
about
under Mifflin office play um
no I'm not asking it I'm just reading it
out loud oh I'd like to hear the answer
well let me see I would um
I guess everything's okay
why don't you open your present no no no
no no no no no no no this hey hey hey
hey this might not be what I think
that I don't even know is in there
because there are a lot of presents in
my car and I don't know which is which
suck on this
what the hell is that Michael that's
what do you mean Michael
that's not even my handwriting hey
what the hell is going on here
who thought it would be hysterical to
give Toby a rock for his going away gift
you did no you made me rap it I thought
it was over the line and I just okay
this is the worst you were the worst I
ate looking at your face I want to smash
It come on Michael you're interrupting
you're kidding me God you say radon is
silent but deadly and then you expect me
not to make farting noises with my mouth
what is this you know what we're not
gonna die of radon we're going to die
boredom yeah right and if I had a gun
with two bullets and I was in a room
with Hitler Bin Laden and Toby I would
shoot Toby twice
okay all right really funny and then you
went too far anybody need sunblock got
SPF 30. oh you know what uh you're not
going
say yeah I know I'm sorry Toby we um if
somebody has to stay here I want today
to be a beautiful memory that the staff
and I share after I have passed on to
New York
and if Toby is a part of it
then it'll suck
why are you the way that you are
honestly every time I try to do
something fun or exciting you make it
not that way
I hate
so much about the things that you choose
to be
I know what you want to ask me
did your mom ever see you naked you can
do this with more privacy so you can
molest me okay I don't think so
we're gonna leave the blinds open so
everybody can see what a big failure you
are
the key
Toby is in HR which technically means he
works for corporate so he's really not a
part of our family
also he's divorced so he's really not a
part of his family
see ya
Far and Away the most expensive shot of
the movie but it was integral to the
story
great practical joke Jim can we go to
the annex
no oh God
no God please no no no no
no
David wait no is there no way we can get
rid of him
not without cause Michael I have cause
it is because I hate him you like to
imagine a place that you feel very
peaceful
okay for me it's the walk from the
yogurt shop to my car after I drop my
daughter off on Sunday afternoons
all right
oh my
that's why people are leaving
I
I have no words
we should really have the office's air
quality tested I mean we have radon
coming from below we have asbestos in
the ceilings these are silent Killers
you are the silent killer go back to the
annex
you'll see so Costa Rica that was
did you have fun that must have been fun
well
um it was amazing
it really was thanks for asking um the
beaches were pristine speeches
the whole thing was incredibly cathartic
why'd you come back why don't you stay
well it's actually kind of hard to meet
people I bet for you and uh yeah this
was hot
why don't you get an air conditioning
should have got an air conditioner for
yourself are you all right one I am I am
I tried I tried
I tried to talk to Toby and be his
friend
but that is like trying to be friends
with an evil
snail
I feel like I'm dying inside
you don't hear a lie and I think you're
great
you're my best friend
uh what's your favorite flavor of one
hour what one hour we've done one hour
let's just
speed this up okay keep it moving I want
to do all six hours oh look I can't
count the hour if you don't talk no no
no
no I know my rights all I had to do is
sit here for six hours do my time
Michael it's up to me to check off the
boxes and I can't do that unless you
have any idea how angry that is making
me tell me I was joking Toby all right
he didn't seemed like he was joking well
you don't get it because Stanley is a
beautiful sassy powerful black man and
you're
you if you had any friends you would
understand friends joke with one or not
you know Michael so sometimes my
daughter's stomach hurts when there's a
mean girl at school well sometimes my
stomach hurts when you come into my
office so it's probably psychological
Toby can I really tell you anything of
course
well the other night
I was sitting at the table eating my
penis
I mean peas
that was weird that's weird I think it
all stems from the fact that I was
I was probed
by an alien life force an Alf
you know I might have actually been
pro-bius
you might think he's a puppet
never see the lower half but there's a
lower half
it's very important for you to be light
isn't it well
let's not get too
this isn't a counseling session
okay
you son of a gun
you son of a wow okay just you
help you Michael God
you're very helpful aren't you you try
to help everybody do you want to play
another game you are good but you know
what you can't help people you couldn't
help your marriage lose you lose I don't
need your help nobody needs your help
nobody wants it
you can't help anybody I don't need your
help